okay let me give you an alternative that
is one of them you can shame somebody
but you could also say you know what
you could be so much more beautiful if
you're healthier you know try something
like that yeah
if that works then America wouldn't have
a I can't say that an obesity issue
because
de Nova people genuinely mean like the
body positivity that's huge in America
we're huge it's not much better here you
guys are much less obesity no no because
then that's what I'm saying do you know
why we're not why people hear more being
is actually is because they're not
taught how to be better to themselves
for example I'm Portuguese I know listen
my diet listen the diet the the things
that people miseducated all the time the
food here is discussing I'm not gonna
lie I come from Portugal I know the
difference between the population then
the population here it's all because of
miseducation we are not taught to tell
people to have the tools to
independently grow that's an excuse me